We mentioned that with future context we can talk about the future using the present.
For example, we had tomorrow, which was
Manana.
Maniana, good.
We had later or more late, which was Mastarde.
Mastarde.
We had tonight or this night.
Esta noche.
Good.
Another one is uh pronto.
Pronto.
What do you think pronto means?
Now.
Aura was now, no?
Ah uh soon?
Soon.
Yeah, you hear in English sometimes get here pronto.
No?
It's get here soon.
So pronto is also future context.
What was the verb to see or to view?
Ver.
He sees?
They.
Good.
They
Ven you informal
Vemos.
Very good.
The I version is a tiny bit irregular.
It's beo.
So you have V-E-O.
So it's not V as it should be or Bo.
It was too short.
It became B.
B.
V-E-O.
Bel or Vil.
How would you say I'm seeing her later?
I'm seeing her later
That means I see she later
It's not la.
It is?
Oh, so it's la veo.
La veo.
Good.
Yes.
La veo mastarde.
I'm seeing her tonight.
La Veo esta noche.
Good.
La veo esta noche.
We are seeing her soon.
La venemos pronto.
What is to say?
Oh sorry, it should be them vemos?
Yes
Yes.
So no guessing.
No blessing at all.
It's the only one, huh?
La vemos pronto.
Good
What if we say we're seeing, we will see them soon?
But with this them, we mean a female group.
We're seeing them soon.
Las Vemos Pronto.
Good.
He is seeing them soon.
And this time they are still females.
Las ve pronto.
Good.
And you informal?
La ves pronto.
Them soon.
You're seeing them.
Las
Ves pronto.
Good.
Now make it a question.
Are you seeing them soon?
The female them.
Las ves pronto.
Aren't you seeing them soon?
Good.
Very good.
So we saw that with future context we don't need the future.
If we don't have future context, we can still use the present to talk about the future using this I go or I'm going
Which is present, but we can use it to talk about the future in Spanish as we do in English.
I'm going to see her.
We're talking about the future.
We're going to see her.
So let's practice that.
How would you say we are going to see her?
Vamos a ver la are you going to see him soon?
Speaking informally, are you going to see him soon?
So you can't work with ear, which is two go.
You should probably work with vamos and work backwards.
Vas.
Good.
Vas a verlo pronto.
Vasa verlo pronto.
The word for us is nos.
So how would you say, are you going to see us soon?
Are you going to see us soon?
And we're still speaking informally.
Vas a ver nos pronto.
Very good.
Where else could that nos go?
At the beginning.
Before the changed verb.
Nos vas a ver.
Very good.
Nos bas a ber pronto, aren't you going to see us soon?
Novas
A ver pronto.
Nos pronto.
Good.
No vas a vernos pronto.
Either way.
Why aren't you going to see us soon?
Porque no vas a ver nos pronto.
Good.
So we've seen that we can use the present to talk about the future.
Using going to or also using future context.
Word like tomorrow, next week.
Next week is the week that comes and the week is La Semana.
La semana.
How do you say the week that comes?
So what is the word for that?
Which is the same as what?
La semana ke the week that, the week which
comes and here we mean the week comes so it's it comes.
So what is it comes?
Vene.
Viene.
Good.
So next week is la semana che viene.
The week that comes, la semana che viene.
So you could say let's speak and to say let's speak we know from vamos you can just use the we form so to speak is
Hablar.
We speak.
Let's speak next week.
Let's speak the week that comes.
And now I've forgotten come.
It's okay
Okay, if we forgot it we need to find it again.
That's not any problem.
Every time we do find it, we strengthen that process, and that's what we need.
Not to remember the word.
the process we need to strengthen.
I want you to know how to find to come and then to go from the it comes.
Take your time to find it comes
Bene.
It would be bene, but viene.
Let's speak the coming week.
At the moment you have you have the whole sentence in your mind and you want to translate it.
Now this process works when you're memorizing.
But we're not memorizing.
We're doing something else.
We're building.
So we must
reduce it down to the smallest piece we could possibly think about.
Think about that piece, get it out, then forget it.
So the first bit is we speak, let's speak.
The week la semana which or that comes
Yeah.
Good.
Hablamos la semana que viene.
What was to see what to view?
Ver.
What is we see?
Vemos.
If you want to say we see each other
You say we see us.
Nos can mean us, ourselves, each other can mean all of that.
Nos.
So how do you say we see ourselves?
Nos vemos.
This is a way of saying uh goodbye in Spanish.
We see each other.
Now the future context here is the fact that you're saying goodbye.
But we're using present because we know when we say nos vemos, we don't mean we're seeing each other right now.
We mean we will see each other again.
We're not even mentioning that future context, but it's working, it's allowing us to use the present there.
Nos vemos
Ciao.
Or you might want to say we will see each other next week.
How would you say that?
So piece by piece, we see each other.
I want all of your mental energy on that and not
Thinking yet about next week, how you will say that.
What you're worried about right now in this moment is how you're going to say we see ourselves, and even before that, just we see
So it's vemos and it's nos vemos.
Good.
The week that comes.
So the week
La semana que viene.
Good.
Nos vemos la semana que viene.
So you see it's not important to remember Biene.
We don't want to remember Biene.
This is useless.
In fact, if we memorize Biene, we're just going to be
Glazing over the problem.
What we want to internalize is the process of oh, how do I find this?
So we've seen that we can use the present to talk about the future
using either I are to go to boy a ba mosa ba or using some future context